hallo zu VOG Tag 10 heute rechnen wir
zusammen wie teuer ein Tag in der
Schweiz für uns ist das Essen das
Skifahren das Hotel alles wird heute
offen gelegt Statement von
Vanessa fangen wir mit der Unterkunft an
das jalet Hotel Schöneck ist ein vier
stne Hotel und kostet uns 450 Franken
die Nacht was 475 € sind dafür bekommen
wir aber auch ein Zimmer mit
mathornblick skiequipment ausline kostet
ungefähr 60 € pro Tag ich habe Stöcker
Skier und Skischuhe timo hat noch dazu
ein Helm kommt drauf an was man braucht
aber ja für meine Equipment ungefähr 60
€ pro Tag wir haben uns jetzt für heute
ein Skipass geholt und mein Beginner
sheipass kostet ungefähr 59 Franken das
sind so um die 60 € timus sheipass so
ein richtiger kostet 90
€ derip kostet zwar 60 Franken pro Tag
aber der Spaß ist
unbezahlbar super hasten wie du das
gemacht hast die stirbt jetztte die
stirbt
nicht e krank ein Glühwein nach der
ersten Abfahrt
8,50 jawoh
geil
[Musik]
zweiter Glühwein nach der zweiten
Abfahrt und für Timo ein Radler 1670
Franken aber wann trinkt man schon
Glühwein mit so einer Aussicht und es
gibt sogar einen kleinen Keks
[Musik]
dazu
zur Mittagspause sind wir oben auf dem
Berg eingekehrt dort findet so eine Art
Selfservice statt da kann man sich viele
verschiedene Dinge aussuchen preislich
aber alles trotzdem sehr teuer ich neh
Rö mit
Spiegelei okay also einmal Rö mit einem
sehr
sunnyide
upck und
bratbuss das wichtigste jetzt oh mein
Gott ich se richtig aus ob ich den
ganzen Tag skfahren
W 58 Franken de hat 2350 gekostet meins
2050 und 7 € für die
Getränke ich weiß Leute es heißt das
Matterhorn das das das das das der Berg
das ist
VI
[Musik]
Leute ich bin das erste mal wo mein
Gesicht voll kalt ich bin das erste mal
runter an Hindernissen vorbei an Kindern
vorbei oder ist jemand
gefallen ver den Spaß
ja die Piste bekommen hat richtig
gemerkt dass du nicht so davor bist
kleine kurveel angehalten total unsicher
und jetzt ist einfach geflt und die
ganze Fest halt einfach Gefahren ein
erfolgreicher Skitag endet natürlich mit
apri hier sind die Preise wirklich
ähnlich zu den pistenpreisen und wir
haben uns für zwei Aperol Spritz
entschieden ein Klassiker unter den apri
Drinks aber W nicht wirklich Skisaison
haben und es ein Montag war mussten wir
ein bisschen Party
faken ye wir haben so viel
Spaß
ein Aperol Spritz 13
Franken für uns war apri aber nach einem
Getränk vorbei denn wir hatten noch
große Pläne wir wollen heute Abend noch
Käse von dü Essen ein absoluter
Klassiker unter den Schweizer Gerichten
und dafür mussten wir quer durch die
Innenstadt von dem kleinen süßen Örtchen
Z mat und selbst der Regen hat uns
nichts ausgemacht vom Abi haben wir uns
jetzt auf dem Weg gemacht zum essen ganz
klassisch und der Weg h oh ist schön
guck mal das der
Weihnachtsmann im Grand Hotel ne es muss
irgendwo sein wo Edwards gastrobar ist
ah
da ja h r schon mal nach irgendwie
furzkäse also wir haben hier Käse von D
in ganz vielen verschiedenen
Preiskategorien es gibt das klassische
Hausart mit Birn
tomatenfondu frische Champignons
Gorgonzola Chili
bierfondu und käsefondü mit Prosecco ich
denke mal wir nehmen das klassische ne
Käse vonü wir wollen da nicht zu
verrückt werden 27 € pro
Person für Schweizer Preise klingt das
gerade nach einem
Schnäppchen also man nimmt hier sein
Brot wir müssen Euch Käse von dün nicht
erklären und dann tunt ihr das so rein
i lecker boah siehst du wie es dampft m
timo hat schon gesagt das schmeckt wie
eine käsige
[Musik]
Suppe noch
Alkohol
hi hallo also das Käse von D müssen wir
leider sagen hat uns überhaupt nicht
geschmeckt
absolute alkoholbombe ja es hat so nach
Alkohol geschmeckt auch und es hat immer
so geschmeckt wenn man es im Mund hatte
als ob so das der Alkohol noch im Mund
weiter verdampft so aber ich glaube der
war auch einfach nicht heiß genug
erhitzt dass das halt so ein bisschen
verdam ich glaube schon aber sie hat ja
gesagt dass irgendwie Wein drin und noch
irgendwie ein Schnaps hat sich angefühlt
W so ein Liter Ethanol einfach da
komplett reinladen ja also war ein
bisschen drüber muss ich sagen ich habe
mich so gefreut ja ich habe mich auch
mega darauf gefreut ja aber ansonsten
tolle Erfahrung in der Schweiz mal Käse
von dü zu
essen für 60 € nee immerin besser als
mein erstes mal Fleisch von D wo ich mir
einfach den fleischpieß in in Handballen
reingejagt habe ich war auch sehr froh
dass diese Gabeln kein Wiederhaken
hatten okay ja und jetzt laufen wir hier
gemütlich nach Hause und Rechnen mal zu
Hause zusammen was uns der ganze Tag so
gekostet
hat kommen wir zum
Kassensturz das Hotel ist natürlich so
eine Ausgabe die ist ein bisschen
variabel ne man kann sich ja auch ein
Dreisterne Hotel gönnen oder ein Airbnb
oder ein zweisterne Hotel oder was weiß
ich unter der Brücke schlafen das muss
jeder für sich selber wissen wir haben
jetzt für diese Reise mal das ausgewählt
weil wir auch was schönes zum Film haben
wollten und natürlich die Anfahrt ist
sehr variabel also ob du jetzt aus
Berlin ankommst oder hier um die Ecke
wohnst das sind natürlich
unterschiedliche Preise wir rechnen
jetzt einfach mal zusammen was uns zwei
zusammen dieser Tag gekostet hat fangen
wir mit den Getränken an 18 € ich bin
richtig verwirrt weil wir einmal
Glühwein in so einem richtig schönen
Holzhäuschen getrunken haben was viel
hochwertiger war und da war der Glühwein
günstiger als auf diesem Berg wo man
sich das in einen steroporbecher selber
reinkippen musste und bei dem anderen
gab es eine Orangenscheibe und einen
kleinen Keks dazu und also die Preise
hier machen teilweise echt keinen Sinn
1762 fürs zweite Mal Getränke jetzt
kommt der Tagespass
165 € das ist ganz schön viel weil es ja
nicht mehr so lange hell ist und ja komm
für 4 Stunden Skifahren 165 für zwei
Personen dafür kann man viermal ganzen
Tag im Heidepark verbringen Ausleihen
von den schin für 60 € ja was weiß ich
jetzt kommt noch unser
Mittagessen 61 € und unser Abendessen
85 € da sind wir jetzt bei
406,62 und ich habe das Hotel noch nicht
mehr mit reingezählt 475 € die Nacht 800
81,62
€ dafür fahren wir teilweise eine Woche
in den Urlaub Timo was wir hier an einem
Tag verpassen wir haben ja aber auch ein
vier Sterne Hotel wir haben uns dieses
Mal richtig gegönnt man kann ja auch z.B
in ein D oder zweisterne Hotel oder in
Airbnb oder es gibt sicher günstigere
Alternativen auch hier in zermat wir
haben uns natürlich so ein bisschen
gegönnt auch fürs Film damit wir was
schönes haben zum Präsentieren aber ja
80 und wie wie lange wie viel Tage waren
wir jetzt hier also aktive mal d
ungefähr ne in di Tagen mit Skifahren
mit Essen mit allem drum und dran haben
wir ca
€ ja kein Wunder dass ich in meiner
Kindheit nie Skifahren war weil das
einfach für reiche Menschen ein Urlaub
ist muss man einfach so sagen ja aber
Schweiz ist noch mal extra teuer das ist
schon insane hier finde ich Schweiz ist
extra teuer ja das ist schon krass also
generell Schipass und so ist schon immer
teuer aber ich find hier allein auch so
die Essen und so ist so krass te
e immer so 40 Franken für ein so Gericht
ja ja gut ich meine wir h auch zu
McDonald's gehen können aber ich glaub
selst mcdonal ist hier teurer ich muss
auch ehrlich sagen ich hätte diesen Ort
jetzt nicht ausgesucht wenn nichtog
gedreht hätten wenn wir nicht schon eh
in Mailand gewesen wären und das auf dem
Weg gewesen W zwischen Mailand und
Basel und ich bin happy dass wir es
gemacht haben aberlich bei solchen
Preisen ste man auch glücklich sein am
Ende des Tages ne
trotzdem das ist
Teer wir sehen uns dann morgen ne
tschüss